so I want to play a game called this or  that okay okay at the movies candy or  popcorn dogs or cats dogs love or war  gonna say fraternity or sorority  breakfast club or pretty in pink  Wow well you're in pink that makes sense  beer or liquor liquor I'm underage  Zac Ephron shirtless or fully dressed  yes you wonder why is great fashion  sense great fashion sense Seth Rogen  shirtless or fully dressed  Antron or rogue I'm gonna say the gut  instinct reaction was broken so I think  he probably that's all pranks or hugs  thanks  pranks yeah nice one over here all right  having neighbors are not having  neighbors neighbors chloe moretz or  chloe regrets neighbors one or neighbors  two two partying or Netflix and chilling  I think the correct answer is go to  movie theater and use Fandango oh thank  you thank you so much  you